what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch
Reacher episode 4 today John how's it
going hi Roscoe oh oh you're my you're
my Finley over here I'm excited to reach
Jack reach you're my Reacher and I love
Jack Reacher I just want to cuddle with
you in a motel exactly like Jack Reacher
just as big as him you're just as stoic
and you get things done G I'm the Jack
Reacher around all right fine I'll be
Finley and Roscoe how about that oh
you're just Roscoe
leave a like I'm Hubble it was stupid
like stupid and uh full-length Reaction
watch along this resync over your own
copy available for super sexy rejects
massive appreciation to all who have
already joined courtesy of this show but
also we cover things exclusively over
there with reaction highlights and watch
along it's included all right let's do
it
laughs
wow nice
I know he's dead but first cut it out
Fierce games right there
I know there's a point no one needs to
correct me but it helps engagement so go
ahead and correct me
and you look tracking down Spivey dead
end I found out Hubble's been lying to
his wife hasn't worked at the bank in a
year guess we could throw that into the
what the heck does that mean pal
why am I chasing down one of his pigs
found it Roscoe told teal the plates
matched one of Morrison's old College to
throw him off the scent
there are no plates yep
someone took pains to hide it from the
road with brush but last night's Reign
washed away the cover still doesn't mean
it was your brothers we're in big Car
Country could be stolen would have been
reported missing by now big cow country
big Car Country big Drifter country fire
didn't start in the engine of the gas
tank
and starkist in the center then spreads
out sell the rent in the match
it's Roscoe Roscoe you can send photos
to forensics
old Army trick
when you run out of Gun oil acetic acid
from ketchup salt for abrasion
make a great metal cleaner is that why
you went and got fries and they were
tactical fries all along you gotta find
these guys before they kill any more of
our leads but they won't talk why not
I'm a good interrogator not that good
have you seen Finley with the Ouija
board oh my God his legs
I did that after
it's like Tetris yes it is
carrion Tetris you shot them in the back
you just told Finley they charged you I
told Finley what he needed to hear
Baghdad
I need to know what kind of person I'm
working with so what happened in Baghdad
Reacher Reacher Baghdad group of boys 10
11 years old played soccer and a bombed
out hanger every day whenever they see
me they'd wave
I waved back
one night it got real late they hadn't
returned so you shot them
I went back to the hangar so they
wouldn't have to walk back alone
three men from the village were abusing
the boys
you can fill in the blanks oh gross they
could turn themselves into Iraqi police
so they'd answer to me
I knew they'd come for me oh my
so when they did
I was ready
woof then I nailed each of them to a
wall and cut their nuts off you have a
problem with me killing people who hurt
children because I want to know the kind
of person I'm working with
holy howdy
way to spin that I guess I don't
good
now let's get to the airport and dump
these bodies
on the next flight out of here
if I had a security job I would assume
someone's robbing us anytime again
ditch the evidence she still paid a
hundred dollars for parking
oh boy wowie could have worn gloves yeah
really
[Music]
so much cow feed it's got to be drugs
they must be doing something to the cows
it's in the meat maybe they're the ones
stealing all the cow's tongues read that
news story when I asked Mosley what kind
of business Kleiner was in he said
Trucking real estate chemicals
what he didn't say
cowing agriculture agriculture
I already told you a delivery like
that's pretty normal for these parts
it was a hell of a lot of animal feed
is this really necessary lots of Jags in
the city but only one which place will
recognize
we need a room from floors three to
seven if you have it king or two queens
two queens
that's us you dumbass put it under
officer Welty first name Eudora
e-u-d-o-r-a
the door and Welty
fan of a writing surprised you've heard
of her I like short stories
it's a lot about a person by their
student names
take form of what you will but I like
forgotten vice presidents and Yankees
second baseman huh but none of that I
would have checked us in under really
real
oh she's a perfect dude should have
gotten one queen-size bed
unlikely invent someone tracks us here
this won't keep them out but it'll slow
him down give me a few extra seconds get
my shot off nice wow oh he's talking
about a gun
I just need to finish before they come
in
I tracked down a lot of Joe's files
pertaining to this case I I don't know
if it's everything but it's
voluminous nice word I
were to finally
me Joe told me so much about you you
want to meet her just as much as she
does you to talk about Joe so
I'll wait
just talk
come on Reacher speakerphone reach into
your heart Reacher
go on about how smart you are pain in
his ass sometimes
he said you were a good man and that
even though you were his little brother
he was the one who looked up
super tall
I'm glad he found you Molly path you
didn't take the people easily so you
must be special you must have cared
about you very much
grieving
Jack griever
you're hurting
he's still trying to comfort Molly path
I know it's hot isn't it
[Laughter]
man strong silent emotional type I'm
gonna shower if anybody tries to come
through that door
shoot him keep your eye on the prize
reach her
oh yeah
classic brooding shower scene
yes that's what I want to see Jack lover
Roscoe who's watching the door
no we're both watching the shower door
look at them glutes glute Reacher
why was that scene so short
it's about last night
as far as I'm concerned it changes
nothing
got a job to do
okay
are are you sure
what a frame
and just all that distance you're
looking for our son is PD okay he's fine
but we want to ask him some questions
see if maybe he can help us at all with
our investigation thank good
oh boy
where it's going around town you've been
harassing Mr Kleiner he says you
threatened to put a part of your Anatomy
up into a part of his Anatomy things
regrettably turned acrimonious not my
best moment
acrimonious without sanctimonium leads
to uh Paladin pandemonium
that file contains a rap sheets of a
dozen ex-cons who had a beef with
Morrison find who killed our brother in
arms and maybe we can see if that
inflated paycheck of yours can be pumped
up a little bit more
nice all the other kids with the Pumped
up checks Philly father's on the line
says it's urgent
oh my God Horatio Finley
what if Teal's just being very genuine
and the key to solving this case is Fall
Away
I feel like it could be genuine
yeah must be asked about but I can't
read some of the ingredients I'd prefer
to just give you a copy Picard's his
father oh it all makes sense I want a
Twist I'll only be gone a few hours
oh boy sure you will give her a grenade
big big gun I'm so sorry for your loss
I'm not
okay that's not the reaction that we
were expecting Mrs Joplin Miller I
didn't take his name you did it I warned
him over and over that it was going to
catch up to him you know any other truck
drivers of the place like this who can
pay off their parents mortgage
he's open yeah he was stealing from his
company from Kleiner I assume he took
the units re-boxed him sold him on the
black market it was always boxes coming
in and out of here it's amazing what
you'll tolerate when a guy can throw a
good hump into you whoa cool money
shipped to Florida jobling drives down
with real air conditioners to keep up
appearances fills the empty boxes with
phony cash takes them back up to
Margaret for distribution but not before
he skims him off the top for himself
damn it's a working Theory and Joe's
files confirm it we'll see about that
someone picked it up last week and the
plates get pinned at a motel 40 miles
outside milegrave both car and motel are
under the name Ron Hassey that's Joe use
the names of Yankees backup catchers ah
and he was Yankee's second base got
meticulous records lots of notes
hotel address 1517 Oglethorpe Road
memorize it toss it we need to see if he
left behind some personal items he did
briefcase in a garment bag it picked up
about 20 minutes ago foreign maybe
Hispanic or something thank you
Stevo
it was the Colombians any new someone
might come after him so he'd put him
where they wouldn't look he'd move fast
keep the briefcase dump the Garment back
he's riding a cheetah okay Joe
let's see if you're as smart as I think
you are
no way
[Music]
respiration looks like a punch list
now it's not the time guys eyes on the
prize order to hit us if we split up on
three one two three
[Music]
huh son of a
it's okay you got this you protected you
[Music]
nice
yeah buddy
Jack jumper Jack Leeper nice well done
wow oh I really got hit
very specific fighting stuff
gonna pinch your skull all over
I wasn't gonna do that earlier but now I
will thanks
you made them follow you because you had
Joe's note how did you look out for me
my cop that some girl who needs
your protection clearly
last night changed nothing what the hell
were you thinking oh something clearly
changed Jack lover I was thinking when
Joe died there was almost no one left in
the world I cared about
and that felt bad
and then I met you
I felt better oh
caught feelings Jack lover it's your
fault Roscoe you went into that shower
this is true Jack shower
Davison took the car from Picard and
Stevenson could have known his voice
deciphered the meeting location and
Kleiner could have had guys ready and
waiting by the time you arrived your
office could be bugged I can't believe
Stevenson's dirty I guess he was asking
a lot of questions
pretending to be concerned about the
hubbles
God that stinky piece of don't
believe it yet I know you don't need
protection but I went with my instinct
just like I was taught
flashback my boys were only standing up
for Billy Joseph and your kid smashed
and other kids face him he's going to
find some reason to bust you down a rank
cut your pay transfer you out of Okinawa
to some assignment in Germany these
kids you're 12 reach I'm not letting you
get involved but Joe I think was to keep
your mouth shut
it was the right one
now stay out of it and that's when Jack
started weightlifting even his brother
called him Reacher John Wayne's garage
and Grace Connor fall already been to
jelvin's garage so WB is William Bryant
economics professor at Princeton SC is
Professor Stephanie Castillo also at the
European conference also back in three
days
Memphis office the EPA
the hell does any of this have to do
with counterfeiting or South America or
animal feed okay you've got to give the
last one a rest it was a hell of a lot
of animal feed global warming methane
cows this case is hurting my head
I know a pi who can help someone we can
trust trusted with my life on countless
occasions
she hasn't let me down once oh my God
this character is a big Easter egg from
the books and I'm so excited for Kobe
Smulders she's coming my brother was
working for Secret Service he was
looking at a counterfeiting in Georgia
last week he got too close to the truth
someone killed him for it you okay my
brother was killed not me my mistake
about who I was talking to
JW it's all I have number and initials
all I need if you want to talk we just
did
it says Molly Beth's plane lands in 15
minutes she's gonna die how is she gonna
find us she knows what Joe looks like
and I look like Joe
no young blues guy Richard but come on
you gotta feel this
thank you
oh
come on it's okay Finley you got good
music taste
looks like we found her
and looks like she's gonna die she wants
to meet us at the top of the escalator
we got the most conspicuous briefcase
where is she oh she must have missed us
and walked right back no one misses me
when they walk by we need to split up
you take the stairs you take the
elevator
I'm gonna slide down this thing poor
Molly Beth
yeah whoa
what
what ugh
God how do you pick a Direction
God damn it no
what's going on with that dog owner yeah
he's the killer he's the guy all along
can't trust the guy who doesn't feed his
own dog
all right take it away John man
this mystery
it's unfolding quite quite uh uh
oh man I don't even have an adjective
I'm just so blown away now this is this
is a
it's just I don't know I'm loving it a
little speeches yeah I mean I'm really
sad obviously but what just happened but
um I don't know this is just like such a
consistent ride and I think they've done
nicely like this episode in particular
seems like after we did sort of a dive
on Finley a dive on Roscoe now we're
you know on a playing field with
everybody but I feel like this episode
did a slight bit more of like kind of
peeling back elements of Reacher and
sort of digging around we've had
flashbacks and things like that in the
past but I feel like this one gave us at
least in the show's you know laconic way
you know a little bit more of his inner
life in a way that I thought was neat
and interesting and uh I'm excited to
see what becomes of his uh what Neely
was her name his friend
um and uh and and yeah like what a just
a sad and kind of
it's weird it's like it's obviously sad
what just happened to
um Molly Beth but at the same time it's
like a nice in it's really hilarious
yeah because it's like that's not the
right guy he's a twin but uh I don't
know in that dying moment for her to be
in such a stark horrible place but then
to feel like she's seeing you know this
person she clearly had a a strong bond
to you know in her dying moments like
you know obviously he's like oh we gotta
get to the files but I thought that was
like a a nice emotional beat to end the
episode off on and uh and yeah I like
the way that this episode too feels like
things are growing bigger in terms of
the radius and the scope and even though
you know it's it's about what's rotten
and margrave it's a lot of the
surrounding area that they have to rely
on as well
so yeah I'm really enjoying the progress
thus far and the various tensions and
releases and things
what's your take on this one g
think
I think the show just gets better as it
goes and it already started off really
good
yeah I'm really loving it I'm loving it
a lot I feel like Reacher hasn't met his
match yet because whoever took out this
Girl Molly Beth
they're good
they're not far from being inside and
they managed to take her all the way
down some train tracks and shoot her
silencer stealthy killer
I wonder well I mean yeah down down
there with the amount of time it took
them to get there I'm sure you wouldn't
hear it but
if it was it had been a silencer had
someone managed to get a silencer inside
the airport somebody good probably came
in through those tunnels
probably lives in the tunnels that's
right it's a hobo ground it's another
hope
so it's the Bowery King the whole
underground Network right there
yeah
yeah it's sad that's sad I mean this
episode seemed to challenge reach her at
his emotional core
uh you know from being vulnerable and
willing to connect and open up with
Molly Beth to banging Roscoe with the
shower bacon chicken and waffles
Go Jack way to go Jack playing that long
game brother my man my man
and then also what it does to Roscoe as
well her
her wall starts going up after this
happens to me with all the women in my
past
stuff laundry lists
gotta say wow
it's it's like a it's like a scroll it's
a Tome
oh it's a list
2009 alone
but yeah I mean even she starts becoming
all guarded up and if they keep the
they keep the examination on both on on
all three of them I would say but
keeping the examination
on The Duality of both Reacher and
Roscoe I think is really cool RR real
rejects it's all connected
um yeah that and then with Jack having
to
have the face his own emotions as well
but it seems like as he's getting more
comfortable with his emotions Roscoe's
getting actually more uncomfortable with
hers yeah well because I mean I would
have to imagine that it's
you gotta know with the situation like
I'm probably gonna get hurt this guy's
probably gonna leave I can't get too
invested in him but also we both need
this she doesn't like being taken care
of yeah she doesn't like being she's
like she's always had to prove herself
her whole life and she doesn't ever want
to be treated as a damsel in distress
because she bought into this world
culture narrative that's the True
Villain they'll realize it by episode
yeah and then the last episode she'll be
in the kitchen and everything will be
right again and Mark oh pregnant and
everything they're like oh we don't need
to counterfeit anymore you're back where
you belong
um yeah this is this is a good this is
another really solid episode the mystery
is becoming really head scratchy
so far I can't even keep up with the
with the disparate pieces at times I'm
like wait huh I know you guys are
recapping a lot yes there's a lot of
Recaps yeah and we got a lot of and it's
one of those shows where too it's just
people's names
so fast yeah Spivey but he's dead but
then this guy and he was moving ACS but
he's also dead Peter they're the same
person the Hubble might be dead yeah two
Peters and the guy with the dog
flashbacks unfolding yeah
yeah there's there's so much happening
that I'm just waiting for them to delay
like okay okay no it really is just one
straight line my my one bit of reprieve
always comes in when they're going
how is this all connected I don't
understand that I'm going oh thank God I
don't need to understand if they don't
get it I don't need to yeah I'm off the
hook I'm safe all right yeah until next
week I don't know I don't even try to
figure this out uh I'm gonna try to beat
the show at its own game there's so much
wait for you to tell me what's happening
yeah for sure because yeah there's
there's so much information happening at
once that it just becomes and that's why
it's so smart to have you engaged in who
what the characters are going through
good stuff man good stuff all around
yeah yeah Quality quality filmmaking but
it is it is such a it is such a binge
streaming show that you can kind of like
pick apart every every episode and you
know decide for what made this episode
unique or maybe this episode different
and stuff but I really feel like the
long discussion is warranted mainly by
the time you get to the final season
yeah I mean final episode
because yeah for the most part it's like
okay they so designed this to be benched
yeah and I mean well designed but but
yeah very much like the second one ends
it's like oh we gotta keep on moving you
know yeah and then even when the next
one's pick up it's usually like the same
scene yeah uh so yeah I'm like oh yeah
we don't really need to talk too long
about these not until we get to the
final episode
um but as it stands yeah it's a really
enjoyable show and it's a lot of fun and
the back and forth between I keep
feeling like Finley's gonna die though I
should care about Kristen crook
because she's a mom you got kids and I
don't want to see kids die
I wonder if she's involved
I don't know there's something about her
where I'm like she's notable guest but
also she's in like she would be in that
position where you're like oh we've been
protecting you the whole time like I
don't know I think the card's dead
I hope yeah like I I
don't know I'm rooting for Picard and
Finley I feel like they could make it
through I feel like Picard I I could
sense that he like he might come back to
a bad situation I could see the car
dying I'm holding out hope that Finley
will make it I can see Picard dying and
then having us think Finley's gonna die
but it's really Roscoe who dies oh that
would break my heart bone it does a
number on Reacher and he wouldn't want
to leave Mark has been like he might be
tempted to stay behind for her and
settle down you gotta kill her I love
life yeah yeah kill her behead her
uh-huh yeah and then bury her I think
our good beheading goes a long way
yeah especially if you do it in real
time you know and treat it realistically
oh yeah yeah it's hard to cut off it's
much harder than they make it look in
the movies actually a woman's head yeah
whoa yeah yeah with all that yeah
just be mouthing off and complaining the
whole time
yeah I'm just trying to emasculate you
as you're hacking away oh that's that's
the best you got that's the best you got
why can't you sever both of my arteries
at the same time oh big man huh
best I got anyway guys
that's how we think yeah
four win we think four and in spite of
women
all right well
yeah foreign
bad times everyone who comes into
contact with you Reacher dies yeah
you're cursed where's that line where's
that line it's coming give it to like
episode everyone who comes across you
dies yeah including my my heart
because it'll be Roscoe says it
and he'll have to look at himself real
hard in the mirror he'll have to take
another brooding shower but it won't be
interrupted this time it'll just be a
shower
I'll never wash the guilt away
and then everyone in margrave is dead
and he just leaves never solving the
case such a good cinematic brooding
shower look
Palms against the front water pouring
down never taking a shower like that
well you know you just need to have like
a big you know traumatic life event and
then you know you'll be pressing those
walls in no time it's like a little hard
to breathe
yeah because I'm just gonna be running
down your nose and mouth
I feel like you gotta you gotta hold
your breath for the long exhale on that
one
that is a
camera is here kind of trope
anyway guys what did you think about
this episode of Reacher thanks so much
for being here
this is fun it's good stuff I love this
good stuff terrific only four more
episodes to go then we rewatch Jack
reach for one and two never go back and
then we rank every episode and movie
foreign I think that line is in there
about when he has to drive to the
hospital I think that's in the movie
oh about everybody everybody you touch
dies or whatever no what he has to drive
to the hospital oh
there you go
dude
it's all full circle see they were true
to the they were true to the source
material in the movie yeah
it's still a good translation it's still
ideal I'm still the best one yeah
alrighty guys thanks so much for being
here we'll see you soon
[Music]
thank you